ben affleck and jennifer lopez's exes
are here for the rekindled romance it
feels really good and it's really nice
but i'm
so happy a source tells e.t that
jennifer gardner and mark anthony are
continuing to be supportive and there
doesn't seem to be any ill will across
the board quote
they all just want what's best for each
other and their families
i'm excited about it jayla was
previously married to mark from 2004 to
2014.
they shared 13 year old twins max and
emmy they're so big and
so amazing and happy as for ben he and
jen gardner were husband and wife from
2005 to 2018.
they have three kids together daughters
violet and seraphina
and son samuel now with everything going
on you and jen always still manage to
co-parent how do you guys make
all of that work and what are your kind
of areas of expertise with the kids
my areas of expertise is the kids are
spotty at best
it's not homework how do you make all
that work i mean you guys got a lot
going on we do our best we don't try our
best
the source adds that their kids just
want to see their parents happy
and max and emmy are so glad to see
their moms so in love
super loving and supportive during this
time
and this time things are getting serious
the soar says that jlo and ben really
feel like this is it
quote they have insane on another level
chemistry
they are both super passionate and are
head over heels with each other
just like they once were you guys want
to get used to seeing us again
and get this according to the source ben
and jen feel at this point in their
lives
they are undeniably made for each other
quote
everything feels a hundred percent
natural with them once they rekindled it
was like no time had passed
they couldn't be more in agreement if
you missed it ben
and jen were recently spotted house
hunting in los angeles
seemingly confirming they're ready to
take the next step just taking it one
day at a time
taking it in stride i'm super excited
of course we know the duo previously
dated back in 2002 and got engaged
later that year but they ultimately
called it quits in 2004.
ben was your first heartbreak it was my
first it was my first kind of heartbreak
really yeah it was just one of those
things you know i was an adult we were
about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know it was like
a tough one for me but seems like this
time around things are looking like
anything but tough the couple has been
celebrating the singer's 52nd birthday
and vacationing together in europe over
the last couple of days
ben's good friend matt damon had this to
say about their intimate trip
there's a lot going on in france right
now did you call ben up and say what
gives man why didn't you give me an
invite
no i think that's a private trip i don't
think i'd be invited on that one i might
be a bit of a third wheel
we feel you matt case in point this pda
packed pick
that made their relationship instagram
official
52. j.lo shared these snaps living her
best life on a private yacht in san
tropez
we won't want to give it away but it has
a very good idea and if you kept on
swiping
waiting at the end was a passionate kiss
with her man
the couple were also seen celebrating
another birthday
this time it was jen's close friend leah
remini in the black and white photo with
remini
ben is seen wrapping his arms around the
two besties like he never left
[Music]
so what makes bennifer 2.0 work now well
the source says that the relationship
is easy and they're always working as a
team they don't tend to bump heads
i think we have chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
you